I've been told that I am very like
bootylicious so I'm just worried that
it's a look that I won't be able to find
anywhere else and this might turn into
have it I hear they are comfortable
they're attractive I guess I don't know
leggings make me thirsty
cuz the kids say so these are more of
your standard jegging these are really
nice these scream my name good thing I
wore underwear I'm not prepared for this
video which is why I'm wearing robot
boxers today we don't show that pants of
the past get out of here here we go
these are really colorful Oh like a
frickin glove and now it just feels like
I'm getting into a leotard that kind of
the ladies move the girls do this move
in private to get these things on this
is ridiculous this is ridiculous my
penis is doing the division sign right
now I got a testicle here testicle here
it is I think this is my new style
who needs jeans this is much better
well I should be worried about like I
think these are like you wear a thong
with these right I look like a chicken
feel like a gazelle or a gazelle
Giselle's Tom Brady's wife I guess I
feel like her too like I can kick really
well that's pretty good they're warmer
than I expected they are really feeling
the flavor I feel like a very weird
Superman right now this is like with
spider-man where's spider-man wasn't
even into like fighting crime he just
wanted to wear this and be comfortable
he's tight I feel feel athletic
I wish it was socially acceptable for
guys to just wear this I'd say you know
go for it like if you really like how
these feel on you as a guy or if you
identify as a guy I say go for it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]